ladies and gentlemen
give it up and stand up for i heart
radio icon
jennifer lopez
[Applause]
yep ben affleck is one proud boyfriend
as jennifer lopez accepts the icon award
at the 2022 i heart radio music awards
for you know being an icon and i always
admire j.lo who didn't she's just an
icon in such a powerhouse and really
paved the way for women in the industry
she's like gorgeous and she's like an
insane dancer and
she does it all she's connected to
something divine
i mean like to put it simply she just
knows more than all of us
she's a goddess here's the waiting for
tonight singer looking stunning on stage
in a beautiful olive green gown by
stefan roland meanwhile in the audience
ben couldn't help but beam ear to ear
sitting front row with his 10 year old
son samuel and j lo's 14 year old
daughter emmy all proudly cheering her
on together during her speech jen
thanked those who are important to her
including her fans i really do it for
you guys
i do
and because the love you give me and the
appreciation and the kindness
and the way you let me into your lives
even in a small way
that's what matters to me the most
because of you i get to do what i love
the most in life you realize that your
fans become such a big part of your life
they come here
and they support you
and they they are with you every step of
the way and this year's host ll cool j
was all for the multi-talented artist
being honored with that icon trophy she
deserves it um she's made such a huge
contribution to culture
done so much you know accomplished so
much in so many different genres i mean
she deserves it she is an icon it's true
after receiving the award jen showed the
world why she's an icon
[Music]
[Applause]
but back to then showing support for his
lady love is no surprise because it's
become kind of expected in the benefit
2.0 era baby you're my shelter
shelter from a broken paradise
i couldn't dream it any better if i
tried
that's ben making a small and subtle
appearance in jen's music video for her
ballad marry me and it just turned out
to be something really magical and last
month at the marry me premiere the
father of three was by j.lo's side and
the two did not shy away from showing
off a little pda this is just a good
date night it's a great date night we're
super happy
um
what can i tell you we're just
having a good time i would be remiss if
i didn't say you were standing taking
photos in front of a sign that says
marry me
it's very big i didn't really realize
how big
and as far as taking that next step well
here's what jen said i've heard you say
so many times that you are a hopeless
romantic and you still believe in love
you believe in marriage so like cat you
still believe in all of those absolutely
why wouldn't i
until then we'll continue to stand these
proud boyfriend moments from then